hi i'm not good at interest i'm also not
gonna intro you are cassie evans true or
false true true actually
and you work at greenstock at greensock
yes and they do animation things they do
and i do animation things too excellent
but there's to be none of that today
because this is my episode so
people can look forward to your stuff
which is all going to be visual and
exciting maybe but i want to talk about
the navigation api which is not visual
and it's all scripty it's a nice nice
gradient you've got there pick that pick
that specially yeah there's a big
website full of gradients and every
episode i go and scroll down it and i
pick
two
um you'll see the other one soon oh i'm
excited for that no no i use the
exciting one for the title and the less
exciting one to put code in front of it
so it's it's less interesting start with
a bang
the navigation api is a replacement for
the history api
which i think you you've had some
experience with used a couple of times i
have to look it up every time i use it
and that's totally understandable
because it is a
i think when i started doing web
standards stuff there was two areas
of standards that had clearly
not gone well
one was app cache
and the other one was is the history api
we've managed to get rid of app cache
and
this new api is how we get rid of the
history one
so
built an example uh-huh um this is a
site i've been
using as demos for various bits and
pieces recently it's you it's me
so i wanted to talk about this topic in
at google i o
and they said no they already had too
many talks so this whole thing is like
well
fine i've got my own show do what i want
so that's this
so this is a single page app
and we've got a set of thumbnails of
http two or three episodes
i'm gonna click a link and now we've
just got the the summer ones
and the url changed
uh but it's a single page app it wasn't
a reload just all changed in place
now just to make sure we're on the same
page to begin with
what do you think should happen when i
click the browser back button
it should go back to the page that you
were previously on yes okay that's that
was just calibrating yeah i agree so
here we go back forward and back and
forward
yeah correct i agree
okay a little bit more complicated
i'm going to click one of the videos
and i'm going to click all of the videos
on the side so that was two two videos
[Music]
so
uh there was the zombie dom one and now
this crossfading dom elements again the
url has changed for each one
we also now have a back button in the
app like in the top there we've got that
arrow but i'm going to ignore that for
the moment what do you think should
happen if i click the browser back
button
previous video
i still agree this is good okay because
that's yeah back and forward back and
forth the two two videos there but
and here's where it might get more
complicated
what do you feel about this the the the
back button that's in in the in the
header there previous page
whoa what does that mean
not the previous video you're on i think
the page that you were on before
so we've had
four entries so far we've had so we had
the all the thumbnails
and we had just the summer thumbnails
and then we had the two videos and we're
now on the the fourth of those
so what do you what do you feel it
should go back to and i'm not saying
there's a right and wrong answer here
because like i i'm
i made up an answer but i'm not
confident i think previous page at its
face states so like all of the all the
thumbnails all the thumbnails i think
that's entirely valid it's not the one i
went with i went with back to the
the
well kind of what you said before like
the previous page yeah um
and then now if you hit the back button
it's it is then going to go back to yeah
but i think what you said there is is
valid i think this is um
a kind of gray area of how browser
history works so we had these four
entries
because
essentially browser history is linear
it has to be linear because you've only
got two controls you go back and
and forward but
yeah we had two different opinions there
about
where that back button should go and
neither of them
were
the previous entry in the history we
were both saying it should go back some
some number of entries
and i think that's right because yeah
some of these app like navigations they
feel more like a stack
or something that it's kind of what you
have on android that kind of thing
um
so to make that kind of thing that demo
work um well first up it's like i was
having to handle the navigations capture
them somehow and then do
some kind of
multi-history entry traversal there at
the end
there's an api for
this old and busted yeah this is from
the it came from the days of html 5
back when it was all being written
essentially by one guy
who did an excellent job at most of it
maybe not this one
this is my other gradient by the way you
can see why it's not as good as
it's not as good sorry i should have had
a reaction to that
it's blue to a slightly different blue
so the api gives you these two things uh
back and forward and they do
pretty much
the same thing as the browser back and
forward buttons
we get this one
which lets you go back more than one
or forward more than one uh just by
whatever number you give it there
have you used these before yeah this is
what i've used the push state
so you get to set a state there's the
second argument which is called unused
which is a relic of time and you just
have to pass in an empty string or null
or undefined or something
and then the the new url path and yeah
so this is your single page app way of
changing the url without actually doing
a full navigation
so
if you've done like an spa style thing
before
if you like want to go from one section
to another we've got push date
you can call that whenever you
want but then the problem is like
when would you call it
and the solution tends to be something
like
this
where you have to add a listener to
every link so when that's clicked rather
than do the link thing don't follow the
link we're going to do something else
the navigation api solves this
this is the navigation observation
i was just waiting for you to attempt
that
we get this
navigate event
and this happens
whenever
a navigation is going to happen right
yeah look it's named relatively well so
that's if like the user clicks a link
or a
a form is submitted you get it for one
of those as well all of these things
which would trigger a navigation uh
naturally and you say when it is about
to happen
yes
because you can prevent the default and
do
something else
so rather than add listeners to all of
the links
you just add this one event that's
really handy so this this means that
yeah you can have
a separate routing
element to your application that is just
centralized here and it doesn't have to
care about how the navigation happened
[Music]
um
okay there's a bit of the api i'm less
keen on i'm less keen on this naming
so if you want to intercept one of these
navigations
they call it
transitioning from one
history entry to another within the same
document i don't like the naming because
for me transition means animation yeah
animation it's not uh that unfortunately
so there's there's some that you can't
intercept yeah they should have called
it intercept like there's something that
you can't transition between and that
would be like cross-origin navigations
because it's like that's someone else's
website you don't get to control that
but if it's same origin you can say hey
we're not going to follow the link we're
not going to do a page reload i'm going
to handle this transition
myself
and you get to do something like this
and you say right i'm going to actually
transition this while
i do something else like handle it in my
application
and
you can pass it a promise
and this is this is a new feature for
this like it will do the browser spinner
while so even if it's an in-page
navigation you still get the little
browser spinner doing its thing like
that the rest of the ui acts like
reloading some stuff
that's cool and you also get
an abort signal
and that's there it will tell you if the
user presses the x button
or some other navigation comes in which
has higher priority so if you're doing
like some fetches to get some data you
can listen to that and it'll it'll stop
the fetches happening or you can react
to it in some other way like you know
that's the navigation being being
aborted there isn't an equivalent to
push state in this new model because the
whole idea is you just
make the navigation happen as normal
and then you pick it up in the in the
navigate event
so that it kind of does that separation
of you've got one piece of code that is
like you're clicking just clicking
regular links and then this other piece
of code which picks it up and roots it
all right
final bit this is the history inspection
problem these are all really opaque
titles
i thought like there's a series of
problems i had to try and group them
somehow
um
and the inspection part is is what we
need to do this bit
that we talked about before like this
one where
it jumps multiple steps back yeah
i think this is almost impossible to do
in the the current api
because i
the model we went for is it doesn't
matter how many videos you've looked at
uh when you click that back button in
the top left it's going to go back to
the the index
uh the nearest index i guess which and
this one was the one filtered by serma
yeah i think it's entirely valid to have
gone back to the first one as well but
you know i just went back to the
sermon one because that's the closest
one
in the current history api you get this
and it's you have to figure out what
number to put in there
and this is almost impossible to figure
out because even if you
go onto a page and you figure out like
right okay that last click
i'm now one away from the index and then
the next click right okay now two away
from the index
that doesn't fully work um
and that's thanks to iframes
this is a page
this is a page i've designed myself it's
it's beautiful very brutalist yeah this
is what i've been using in my
two year quest to figure out how
browsers actually handle
navigations and traversals
uh i i should have done a simpler
version of this but i picked it up
because i
we've got three iframes along the top
there
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
navigate the top page to hash foo
and then i'm going to navigate each of
these iframes
now something that catches a lot of
people out something people don't
maybe know about browser session history
is the iframes are included in that
linear
history
so if i click back now
i have to click if i was wanting to
navigate back to the top level i'm
having to click that four times because
it navigates each iframe
and then the top level
and when those iframes were navigated
there was no event for that there was
nothing i was told like as a developer
of the page especially if the navigation
happened entirely within the iframe so i
could have been thinking like oh okay so
back to the indexes go minus two
one click in an iframe and now it's
minus three
it's just booby traps everywhere exactly
yes
and
that's why things like
you look at the code of things like
react rooter and they've had to deal
with all of this stuff as best they can
but
we have the history inspection problem
solution
and that's part of the the navigation
api so it has these back and forward uh
commands
but they're different to the history
but in a good way i think
you can tell me whether it's whether
this is i think i think it's better
it's a little confusing in some ways so
back to where we were before i've
navigated the top level and i've
navigated those three iframes but this
time i'm going to call navigation.back
because i'm calling this at the top
level it's going to navigate the top
level back
and it's going to navigate as far back
as it needs to
to actually do a navigation of that top
level so you see where it says hash foo
there
we run that command
and now we've gone back to that bit so
you know so you're saying that top level
i want you to go back one
and that's what it's actually done but
it has also taken all of those three
iframes with it at the same time when
you say taking the iframes with it is
that if you were to go forward now would
you go step through the iframes yes you
would okay yes so it has maintained that
yeah that linear history and it's so
it's actually taken us back uh one two
three four places by calling back once
so it's it's maybe confusing in its own
way um but it's more reliable from the
pages point of view
i think at some point we might get
an attribute that you can stick on
iframes to say don't take part in linear
history please be your own thing
and i think we i think we need that um
because for things like you know a chat
widget you might have you know in the
corner of a page like a third party
thing you might want to manage its own
history states but not mess around with
the top page itself yeah yeah and we
don't really have that right now
this is what the new thing gives us
you get to
say show me your history entries for
this page and it just gives you a list
of entries and it will tell you things
like the url their key whether they're
saying that confirmation and yeah you
get to look at the state of each one as
well it's exciting
none of this you could do
previously
um and you can also tell it to traverse
to one of them
same document is cool
yeah well it's stuff we should have just
had from the start because the browser
knows all this stuff already less busted
yes yes i really hope so
so here's the code i wrote to make this
happen like this this bit where you know
we were going back and some number of
of history entries to get back to the
index
uh as i say this was totally impossible
before i i think or you know or you
would
you know you might get it right if you
were lucky
or you were you're
carrying loads of state around but with
this new api what i'm going to do here
is
this this is on the that back button
link the back link click i guess if this
new api isn't supported just going to
bail out let it follow the link
as is
otherwise we're going to get hold of
these entries
i'm going to slice them
from 0 to
the current entries index
and that means now i've just got a set
of the back
entries
because it you know we might be in the
middle of a set of entries so there
might be forward ones as well so now
i've just got the backwards entries
and now i'm going to find the last one
which has a path name of slash
or starts with
with slash with because that was the the
uh those index pages like with cerma
with ada with paul
and if i don't have an entry just return
and that just
a normal link click will happen
otherwise stop the link
and traverse to that entry we found
and that's how that was done awesome so
it can just crawl back through the
history entries find the one that
matches
and just traverses to it
um
there's more that i'm not going to cover
there's stuff that handles like
focus states
stuff that handles scrolling state that
i haven't fully consumed and understood
but i intend to because i think it's on
me to update our article
on this because personally wrote it left
never mind um
but i i yeah i think this is like it's
taken that that history api that has
caused so many people so much pain over
the years uh
and that's that's heading for chrome
stable it's behind a flag uh the web
platform experiments uh
flag right now
but it's gonna be stable in the in the
next few months it's exciting it seems a
lot more intuitive
i hope so
because i don't think we get a third go
at this
fingers crossed fingers crossed
oh and
i forgot about this slide
excellent okay i'll be back again